let me ask you a seemingly simple
question i have a picture of fire here
and my question is what is fire
well what would you say if i were to
tell you that fire as we see it these
flickering flames it is nothing but hot
air and i know what you might be
thinking hot air normal i've seen air
that's hot i experienced air that's hot
and i don't oftentimes even see the air
but here i clearly see something bright
something that's emitting light
something that's emitting
electromagnetic radiation
and then what i would say to you if you
were thinking that is it actually turns
out that anything in our universe that
has a temperature above absolute zero
zero kelvin which is pretty much
anything that you will ever come across
in your life
emits electromagnetic radiation objects
with temperature aren't the only way to
create electromagnetic radiation but it
is a major way that's happening all
around us even if you are in a pitch
black room you would be emitting
electromagnetic radiation a tree outside
even if it was dark outside is emitting
electromagnetic radiation you might say
wait but i don't see the tree and that's
because your eyes can only detect
certain frequencies of electromagnetic
radiation
if we look at this diagram right over
here we can see how we've categorized
many of the frequencies and you can see
that up here this is the frequency this
is the wavelength and these are in
powers of 10. so you can really view
this as a logarithmic scale and just
over here you can see that our eyes can
only visibly see a small section of this
logarithmic scale of frequencies one of
the things i like to wonder if humans
didn't have eyes if we weren't able to
detect even the small segment of the
electromagnetic spectrum would we even
know that something like electromagnetic
waves existed
but we could see you have gamma rays
x-rays uv rays infrared rays microwave
fm am radio waves long radio waves and
most hot air
the frequency isn't high enough for us
to see it so most hot air is going to be
in the infrared range only if it gets
hot enough will we start to see it and
that's what's happening with this fire
here and if you look closely at a fire
you might actually see that the location
where the combustion reaction is
happening then that actually might be
dark and then right above that you'll
see some blue flame and then you'll see
maybe if you look closely some green or
yellow flame and then you will see the
orange flame and then you will see the
red flame and the reason why it might be
dark right where the combustion reaction
is happening is that might be very high
energy electromagnetic waves that would
be in the uv spectrum that would be at a
higher frequency than what's visible so
to our eyes it looks dark and then as it
cools it goes through the visible
spectrum and then if it cools enough it
goes to infrared but we human beings
have built the capability to see beyond
what our regular eyes can see
for example
these are what are often known as
thermal images but they're really just
detecting the infrared range so this is
a picture of two dogs it could be pitch
black outside it could be the middle of
the night but because they have
temperature they are releasing
electromagnetic waves which we can
detect and this over here has a scale of
what the temperature must be so you can
see these the eyes of the dog are the
hottest part right over here you can
also see thermal imaging of not only a
hand but after a hand is touched a wall
with our eyes if you were to touch a
wall for say 30 seconds it doesn't look
like the wall has changed at all but if
you were to look at the infrared you
would see that you would have heated up
parts of the wall and you would be able
to see the shape of a hand
and so you can imagine we human beings
because of our ability to detect
electromagnetic waves and explore
electromagnetic waves we've been able to
leverage them more and more in our
everyday lives thermal imaging itself
has a lot of applications firefighters
use it to find people or to find flames
in the middle of a lot of smoke we have
things like x-rays which are high-energy
electromagnetic waves which we can use
to see through soft tissues so we can
see bones this is an old image and it
looks like they're using the x-rays kind
of carelessly you don't want to be
throwing that radiation around but even
today i got an x-ray of my teeth just
the other day when i went to the dentist
when you talk on your cell phone the way
that your cell phone is able to
communicate is leveraging
electromagnetic waves it's
this is another thing that's
mind-blowing to me is that my little
cell phone can actually emit
electromagnetic waves in the radio part
of the spectrum far enough to be
received by a cell tower that could be
10 20 and in certain cases 30 or 40
miles away
microwave ovens literally release
microwaves which are absorbed by our
food which heats up the food and so i'll
leave you there the big picture here is
that electromagnetic waves are all
around us it's most obvious to us in the
visible spectrum because that's what we
can see but there is a large continuum
of different frequencies that the
visible is only a part of and we human
beings have leveraged this phenomenon in
all sorts of interesting ways and i
would suspect that we're just at the
beginning of this exploration maybe you
will come up with a new application of
electromagnetic waves